[Música]
la ciudad de búsqueda en el centro de
francia es conocida por su catedral
declarada patrimonio de la humanidad por
la unesco y por su centro histórico
medieval pero la capital de la provincia
de beja y tiene otro atractivo histórico
las marismas
es un microcosmos poco conocido a tan
solo unos minutos del centro de la
ciudad y desde hace más de un siglo los
locales lo cuidan con esmero
es una isla entonces sólo hay una manera
de llegar bueno dos en barco o nadando
nada
este horticultor vive en la ciudad en un
apartamento después de jubilarse decidió
comprar esta parcela de tierra a pesar
de no saber mucho sobre agricultura
fue sobre todo para tener algo que hacer
busca una ocupación después de haber
trabajado durante 50 años en una
actividad bastante intensa porque era
vendedor en la industria farmacéutica
desde entonces rne vive apasionado por
su huerta cultiva cebolla rábano
zanahoria y lechuga las marismas son un
pequeño rincón paradisiaco que atrae
cada vez más citadinos en busca de
tranquilidad esta pareja ya no quiere
irse les encanta vivir en medio de este
corral donde sus animales andan libres a
solange le gusta ser granjero incluso
aunque sus gallinas sean traviesas
encuentra decenas de huevos escondidos
por toda la parcela y se los regala a
sus vecinos
porque lo hace porque me gusta
no soy una vendedora soy un hada dura
y su marido regala lechugas se jubiló de
su trabajo en los ferrocarriles y ahora
cultiva una huerta en la parcela de
enfrente con el tiempo la marisma se ha
convertido en su segunda casa
en verano nos quedamos aquí mínimo
durante dos meses nos gusta el aire
fresco es difícil de explicar pero una
vez que uno está cómodo aquí ya lo tiene
en la sangre y no se quiere ir venimos
todos los días
[Música]
algunos jóvenes también frecuentan las
marismas se tratan de implementar nuevos
métodos de cultivo
esta pareja se instaló aquí hace tres
años con el proyecto de tener una huerta
siguiendo los principios de la
permacultura
esta particular herramienta es una orca
de doble mango y permite remover la
tierra preservando las lombrices y demás
microorganismos presentes en el suelo
después son ellos los que hacen el resto
del trabajo solo hay que dejar que
crezcan no hace falta regar ni desyerbar
no hay que hacer nada
sin abono sin abono solo amor amor y
también algunos principios christophe
mezcla sabiamente variedades de lechuga
flores y frutos
sembré una calabaza aquí debajo de los
racimos
se va a ver bonito con las flores y
espero que eso también atraiga al pulgón
y lo mantenga alejado de mis tomates
aunque estos huertos son el orgullo de
quienes los cultivan la contaminación de
los canales pone en peligro las marismas
desde el año 2000 clown agraria ha
invadido las aguas esta planta importada
de brasil y vendida en los viveros
amenaza la flora acuática y obstruye las
acequias
aunque es muy invasiva tenemos que
arrancar la aca va a incidir le a los
horticultores que siempre destape en sus
acequias porque crece muy rápido en
agosto su superficie se duplica en 15
días hay que rodearla incluso después de
haberla arrancado hay que poner barreras
para evitar que algún trozo salga
flotando porque vuelve a echar raíces en
otra parte
un poco más lejos el río que alimenta
las marismas trae desechos
retenidos por estas barreras inflables
una pequeña solución obtenida después de
una larga lucha de la asociación de
horticultores
televisión encontramos un televisor
pequeño un tanque de lavadora entre
otros desechos muy diversos pero a usted
no sólo le preocupa lewis y no
exactamente es algo que no se ve y que
revelaron unos análisis hechos en 2010
la oficina nacional de agua tomó unas
muestras aquí encontró excesos de plomo
y níquel en esta parte eso no significa
que los haya en todas las marismas pero
no se encontraron en los sedimentos de
aquí a dónde llega el agua del río
para proteger este ecosistema france
camisa pide que se instalen nuevas
balsas de decantación río arriba y que
el agua se analice con más frecuencia
pero además de la contaminación existe
otra amenaza el abandono de las parcelas
algunas tierras han estado más de 50
años en barbecho
en el tiempo las marismas podrían
incluso desaparecer si las nuevas
generaciones no se involucran más en la
preservación de este frágil ecosistema
[Música]
i